الحرب السائده وانماطها التقليديه تتغير
بتقادم السنين مع تطور تكنولوجيات كل عصر
حرب اوكرانيا قد تتحول ارض اختبارا لذكاء
الصناعي الذي يشهد فورة غير اعتياديه لكن
كيف قد يؤثر في فصولها فذكر الصناعي يحد
اولا من ازهاق الارواح من دون قصد مع
امكانيه تقديمه معلومات استراتيجيه
تفصيليه للغايه عن الاستهداف الاستخدام
المفترض لذكاء الاصطناعي في توجيه
المسيرات واستخدام الاسلحه الدقيقه يتيح
الكييف زياده استنزاف امدادات روسيا
المتضائله من المدرعات ودفع قواتها لفقدان
صواريخ دفاع جوي مهمه كما يشكل اداه قويه
في الحرب النفسيه والمعلوماتيه مع امكانيه
تزييف فيديوهات تتسبب بردود فعل خاطئه من
جانب قوات العدو وتزيد شعورهم بالفشل كما
ذكرت واشنطن بوست الافاده تمتد كذلك الى
الانشطه الدفاعيه في الحرب ضرب لوجيسيات
الخصم التي تعد نقطه ضعف للجيوش اما
الهجمات المضاده فاخطر سمات الذكاء
الاصطناعي اي القدره على اقتحام الشبكات
الالكترونيه للعدو
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات